how this were adorable season 8  Bachelorette star Emily Maynard welcomes  a baby boy with her husband Tyler  Johnson the two shared the first pick to  their new addition on Thursday Emily  first announced her pregnancy back in  January she's already a mom to her 10  year old daughter Ricki whose father  NASCAR driver Ricky Hendrick passed away  in a 2004 plane crash no word on the  baby's name yet but the couple is  definitely well prepared for their  newborn she posted on Instagram who knew  me and the hot guy from church would be  installing car seats together one day  Emily and Tyler have been married since  last June she was previously engaged to  bachelor Brad Womack in 2011 and then to  Jeff home on The Bachelorette in 2012  before splitting with both after their  respective season finales